mes parents nous invitent je peux pas
laisser mon père c'est les premières
vacances depuis que ta chère maman nous
a quittés et tu vas m'obliger à brûler
des sièges tout seul en mangeant des
hottes pourquoi on l'emmènerait pas non
c'est pas une bonne idée
de perle fasse passer pour une sorte de
mafieux ratée
toi tu m'as seulement serré la main
quand tu m'as vu à la maternité bah
c'est normal on se connaissait pas il
travaille pas ces gens ils ont plein
d'argent placé en bourse pas dans des
pots de mayonnaise j'espère que rien ne
disparaîtra ce weekend si l'on sert
tombera tous les coups sur les immigrés
on va vous faire visiter voici d'où
je t'aime ils sont carrément bizarres
ils ont des oiseaux de compagnie il est
un peu de la famille
j'étais angoissé à l'idée de t'amener
mais j'imaginais pas que tu passerais
ton temps à la honte
[Musique]
ma mère ne doit pas voir ça
j'aimerais beaucoup vous faire un bon
dîner italien nous n'avons pas grand
chose dans cette vie là
[Musique]
pourquoi j'ai l'impression que tu l'as
déjà fait